so if you adjust yourself and put your
foot in the middle of my legs and you
put your hips in a bit deeper and you
stretch up a bit more I think you'll
about a delication egg on me
they didn't say anything
they made the adjustments
not all of them but the ones they felt
as if they would adjust
over I go and lovely High fall over
their back get up I come up smiling
yes you've done what I wanted you to do
ego was satisfied on my part
this is them looking at me
hmm
did I do your Technique or did I do my
technique because you seem to be happier
than me
this started me thinking hmm
perhaps I shouldn't be so
forward in the future
especially when I found out that this
person was the person that organized the
whole of psychosemite's massive seminar
and was respected throughout Europe
felt as if
my immaturity
wasn't a gift to him
but it was a gift to me to think about
the future
as when I teach or when I teach as a
student and I stop the person and I say
because I'm perhaps a lot higher than
them I say
try turning your hand over more for sure
Nike
try placing your thumb in before my hand
finally turns over so you're giving
quality detailed teaching from your
experience from your knowledge
from a teacher's point of view
you've switched from being a partner on
a one-to-one even if there's 200
700 once on my map on the mat I was on
but you've become that individual
teacher for that other person
but in your inner
a high Authority and a giving mode
you're not in a in an ego mode or
you know talking to somebody above way
above your level
you're teaching as an experienced person
genuinely wishing to give
the lower grade
you give it with a calmness and a
confidence and a helpfulness
you're not just there
if you move your foot in the middle of
my feet and then you push up higher
and get your hips in more
I think it works that's what you're
doing well
here you go teaching
so when I'm only teaching
someone invites me to teach somewhere in
the world a seminar I'm the only teacher
I teach detail
calmly
I'm comfortable with my teaching of
course I may be
with my second head on me I may be
looking at my own ways of what I thought
I performed the techniques or the way I
presented the words that I gave to the
the onlookers the students in the class
the detail of perfection
has confidence to it
has Comfort to it
possibly works on everybody that you
decide to choose for okay
I try to personally use a lot of
different uks and not just the one that
I brought along with me or the one from
that particular club that the teacher
said oh he's my best UK or she's my best
okay
I've used men and women of all sizes and
grades
and found it a wonderful experience
but I try to choose those who are not so
easy to use
those who I see with other people as
what I call difficult students
the ones they struggle with the ones
that don't go where they want them to go
these are the people that I want to use
because it will show
if the technique can flow and may be the
puppet of them
I must mold my techniques
to their body
what their body will allow them to move
how much it will allow them to move
how flexible they are
and until you use a person for the first
time
you have to find out that extension
their flexibility and it depends
while you're doing it you have to factor
in all these things
and it becomes a beautiful blending
motion
of two people harmonizing together
as a teacher when I was younger of
course the want
to be good
to show perhaps demonstrate
with more a student
wanting to
be looked upon well mother
the students
being asked to teach a seminar wanting
to come back wanting to be asked even
more
to teach other seminars people on the
map maybe from other clubs or they might
invite me to teach if I'm really good if
I show really Dynamic I could do and if
I become
something special in their eyes they
will invite me
this is the same ego
as a student
is when I'm a student training on
someone else's mat under
the Scentsy and not me as being the
Sensei of that seminar